joining me now wisconsin senator ron
johnson and california congressman devin
nunes
um congressman nunes let's start with
you what we're seeing
right now
do you see
a possible bait and switch being pulled
on the republicans here
well i do because you kind of stated in
your opening but mostly on facebook it's
folks that are older you don't see a lot
of kids on on facebook
instagram it's kind of the age between
20 to 250 that are on instagram there
are some teenagers on instagram but the
big boogie man here that nobody's
talking about is tick tock tick tock's
where all the kids are all the little
kids and there's no regulation
there so i think republicans should be
very careful here if anything we ought
to be investigating zuckerberg for the
350 million dollars that he invested
into so-called nonprofit groups that got
involved in our election and i think
that's where the focus should be that's
what every single member of congress
should be asking on an everyday basis
not falling into some trap of figuring
out some scam where we're going to have
a bureaucracy of people that are going
to just do good things which ie means
going to censor conservatives
and democrats uh senator johnson aren't
just looking to use social media
to silence political dissent but also
scientific dissent
last week youtube announced it was
swiftly banning all anti-vaccine
misinformation and i've long called on
facebook to take similar steps we know
the effect of this we know that over
half the people that haven't gotten the
vaccines it's because of something that
they've seen on social media
senator johnson you are actually blocked
yourself from youtube
uh what do people have to understand
about what's at stake here
well first of all i completely agree
with your assessment uh the left by and
large likes media and social media as
they are
what they're trying to do is stomp out
the the last little
tidbit of conservative thought that's
sneaking through facebook
and so we shouldn't fall for it you know
mark zuckerberg
as devin nunes was talking about the the
financing of the elections he pretty
well took over the election system in
greenway wisconsin and had a great deal
of influence in in four or five other
democrat
uh so he obviously is not to trying to
support free speech he i you know i do
agree that he's primarily about making
money and he's craving in terms of how
he's willing to do it but that starts
with parental control
and quite honestly the best pushback is
going to be the free market solutions to
your competitors to facebook uh but i've
never felt there's really a legislative
solution because the democrats like the
status quo they're not going to
cooperate with republicans to to really
reign in the uh the social media
companies because i've nev
what what liberal uh misinformation has
ever been labeled misinformation never
by facebook but what they did do by the
way is they actually shut down facebook
groups of the vaccine injured so that
people lost touch with members of these
groups that were suicidal they could no
longer counsel it that's what facebook
did in terms of censorship of i guess
conservative thought you can't you can't
mention
the vaccine injuries that we're all
aware of
and facebook's uh zuckerberg posted a
statement tonight right before the show
in response to the hearing it's very
long-winded but it says uh in part
similar to balancing other social issues
i don't believe private companies should
make all the decisions on their own
that's why we've advocated for updated
internet regs for several years now i've
written op-eds outlining the areas of
regulation we think are most important
related to elections harmful content
privacy and competition um congressman
nunes uh
does he does he actually think there's
going to be a law written
about what you can post
regarding an election is is that what
he's getting at no what what's going on
there is he had about 72 lawyers and all
of his political people who said look
this is the place you need to land we
need to land here to say that we're for
something uh and and look you would need
60 votes in the senate to actually pass
a law number one number two of course
biden and his regime would love to write
the rules and of course zuckerberg would
welcome it because if you have attorney
general merrick garland drafting the
rules uh it's going to be perfect for
zuckerberg and twitter and
google and all of them so it's it's
really where they're trying to take us
to senator johnson very quickly on this
dod announcement tonight that there will
be
continual surveillance of social media
posts and and that i promise you is just
the start of what they're going to do
with our troops and other dod officials
staffers
real quick your your take on that new
development
i think we need to be very concerned
that our generals are now more concerned
with wokeness
than they are military readiness and i
think they're purging the military
they're trying to get rid of any
conservative out of the military
particularly in the higher ranks it's
part of the purge concerning everybody
isn't it part of the purge here
precisely that should concern every
american
gentleman so great to have you both on
tonight thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else